[Music]
and female serial killer dudes
oh [ __ ] that's about to go down Oh bye
yummy chamoy cuz she's Matlin
she's mad at she's mad at Steve right
now she what are you talking about you
look at the energy I don't feel nothing
but money
a woman has now taken the title of worst
American female serial killer say yeah
you go bro just from my chick the
monster she took it from the monsters
yeah hers the seven victims this lady
seems like there's nine but I want to
point out the worst is actually a female
not a male really no no I don't want to
point out the best chefs in the world oh
she's the worst out of the female female
category in general dumber eight people
yeah okay that's pretty bad and they
just caught the [ __ ] Zodiac killer or
some [ __ ] and yada so what does that
mean what does that mean guys are still
better than girls have little appetite
so they wouldn't want to get that wait
how could you just throw that away they
caught the Saudi I think I just made
that up
who the [ __ ] is a Zodiac John Wayne
Gracie had 34 John Wayne Gacy Gacy sorry
who's that guy who's that guy he's the
clown one oh my god no one Casey I think
30 more plus victim oh my gosh
yeah hurry up and catch up women guys
are the best at killing people
women are more about mentally [ __ ]
you oh yeah it's like your mind and then
maybe when you can't do that you know
what it is it's the Chinese water
torture is what with the slope they come
on laid to death oh you're right you're
right I think oh yeah yeah I felt that
every day yeah you can't affect me if
there's nothing here baby that's what's
up that's what's go be flatline no you
can't no you can't just knows how to
[ __ ] push those buttons yeah I'm
getting better cuz I'm studying Buddhism
scary [ __ ] everybody Buddhist I'm
studying Buddhism
it's so scared they have to study
Buddhism though think because he's so
angry that he has to go to Buddha I
don't even know Buddha was gonna work
cause he's single yeah I would love a
Buddhist girls rose that [ __ ]
crazy
yeah with a boob yet how does a Buddhist
monk give relationship advice serial
killer here so her name is Kelly SH 34
years old this is what she looks like
killer Kelly holy [ __ ] she looks like
she kills that looks like that disaster
artist like Tommy was though as of right
now
she's already serving a life sentence
for shooting dead her lover Chris who
vanished back in 2014 but she was just
recently sentenced to 65 years in prison
for injecting her husband Jason but they
lead lethal dose of heroin in 2016 you
had a lover and a husband yeah so a lady
did yep this lady so it turns out okay
if you're single there's hope for you if
you're single in this day and age or you
should just disappear don't lose hope
there is so the story apparently is that
Kelly and Jason her husband on their
wedding night they created this pact
that if either of them would ever cheat
on each other that together they would
kill the person that they cheered with
that's awesome that's a pact that they
made on their wedding night that's
that's so backwards hey if I ever [ __ ]
up and I cheat on you then let me kill
the innocent all you have to do is just
[ __ ] that's a square deal like what he's
not the [ __ ] people you want to kill
him that's what it's so stupid so it
turns out that she really did love Chris
but she had to stick by that pact and so
she helped Jason kill Chris but then
Kelly was so mad at the fact that Jason
wanted to kill Chris that she ended up
killing Jason girls always going back
ever made a pact that they had to keep
each other alive yeah you got about that
they haven't come on tact but also yeah
but I found a loophole all right damn so
then now her brother Kelly's brother is
now saying that she may have murdered
another nine men in Michigan Indiana
Tennessee and Minnesota
she's got a rage that her lover died I'm
not sure what the stories are with those
because like people because this was a
two-part documentary series on
investigation discovery so they're
pretty much telling the story from the
police chief that was investigating one
of the murders here and so we don't
really know the full story because as of
right now that hasn't aired yet but
they're just saying that she might
possibly be the America's worst female
serial killer sometimes if you just get
I've heard like when they get a taste
for blood like then they just kind of
get addicted to murder especially have
addictive personalities already yeah man
she should have done it like more
healthily like in the military or
something you know doing the military
what we should put them in a mill on the
front lines yeah they're gonna be
killing their own people yeah that's not
reliable they just might just go they
knock them out of there good try though
yeah I didn't mean what if they make
them sign a pact they only shoot the
other guy yeah cuz their honor
yeah she's honorable I'm only gonna
shoot the bad guys or they could just
drop them individually like just one
there yeah you don't get any part of a
troop you're like on your own we can
maybe still use thrower
yeah I wonder if people did that in work
they're like how like that guy so like
when they're [ __ ] shooting
you put peanut butter on my class oh
yeah that was from my other video oh
yeah I don't know this is true that's
pretty crazy and then the girl the guy
Chris he's 51 how do people become
killers the sunchokes so crazy
well here's the thing like when I'm
playing like Battlefield like game
online like I'm basically a serial
killer to my own team and everything cuz
it's fine you can just killing
everything yeah it's just funny and fun
we tried playing fortnight any tried
play he tried shooting his own team
member I didn't know how to play they
don't they don't die on for a night he's
like why won't this person die because I
could see him on radar and I was like oh
it's [ __ ] about to get it right
and it's like Oh Nicky look I'm about to
get this [ __ ] right here and
then and then I'm shooting at him and
I'm like why the [ __ ] won't he die what
the [ __ ] is going on and he's looking at
me like Oh an idiot
yeah she the purge was like there's no
friendly fire yeah I guess that's what
the character did the character looked
right in and was like cuz I guess we're
on a team and I didn't know squad but I
think it's fun right and so maybe you
can't do it in that case they're just
crazy yeah well they think it's fun oh
it's like god I'm not supposed to do
this it's like when you're playing Grand
Theft Auto and you just start whaling on
like a water person walking by and you
just kick them until they're dead and
you keep kicking them even after they're
dead that's kind of fun oh it's fun oh
wait I just made it feels like you're in
LA - yeah cuz it's all LA stuff it looks
like it's a really close it makes my
heart so warm I love that brand yeah you
know I actually forgot to mention the
most important thing about the story
which is the brother is saying that she
served Chris at a barbecue for neighbor
isn't like neighbors ate them oh wait
wait wait
okay that is Jeffrey Dahmer level one
yeah people like what kind of [ __ ]
barbecue is this is so gusty they're
like I love this ribbon it's like a
human rib
oh it's a big week are you know what I'm
not sure if it was Chris it just says
one victim but still the point is just a
human that's very crazy
she's snap do you saw the South Park
episode yeah I made
you eat your parrot yeah the best one
Scot pétomane oh so good there's that
guy in Korea that did that for his
neighbor's dog it's like [ __ ] yapping
and then they [ __ ] kill the dog and
they're like hey guys I have dog soup
and then all everyone's like I love dog
and it came and got some dog I played in
the stereotypes yeah well I mean Dave I
guess it's a special dish dog doggy soup
or something because he's full doggy
Bulldog Bulldog yeah I don't know
imagine being one of those neighbors and
finding out you ate human yeah and
imagine being like this barbecues
[ __ ] good yeah imagine you you have a
taste for human now and you're like I
gotta get right as I say they say that
like once you eat um that's why
cannibalism is illegal also because it's
a minute but like they say that you kind
of like get addicted some people wow
what can I get some [ __ ] human again
I think I read that somewhere maybe I
just made it up but I feel like I've
read them somewhere and I wonder if
different races taste different like the
Asians taste like fish yeah now we got a
taste in Jamali Oh would you have like a
human buffet or it's like all of the
people that get murdered because they
did wrong things and you cook them up
and then you can actually people can try
them that's weird
Tiffani you're saying yeah you went to
an actual logical way of like well we
could go it with the people on life
sentences and you can please I can't
play stick to the articles stuff you're
freaking us out but we'll close a little
bit more today you got the wrong
impression of
everyone else's but it'll probably close
when I said that no it did it again
mine's pretty wide open
well yeah mine's pretty open did you
look at me I'm winking mine right now me
I went back looking at you right now
I Winky - hey Nikki Oh Papa is making me
uncomfortable stop flirting Joe I'm
winking at you I'm doing more Scholl
with my [ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]